good morning almost good afternoon my
name is Jim Levinson I'm the director of
the Jackson Institute here at Yale I'd
like to welcome everybody who's here as
well as welcome our audience as this is
being live-streamed as I understand
around the world one of the things that
we do at Jackson that is a little bit
different is that in addition to
traditional academic faculty in our
classrooms we bring in our senior
fellows who are people who have really
impacted the world around us and it's an
amazing complement to the more
traditional approach to thinking about
issues at a university I can't think of
a better example of how we've we've
we've done this we're privileged to have
with us today
former Secretary of State John Kerry
retired general Stan McChrystal to have
a conversation about Afghanistan I'll
turn it over to you thank you so much we
turn it over to me for a sorry okay well
good morning everybody it's a great
privilege to be back here at Yale as a
veteran of 28 years the United States
Senate I guess it's nice to be invited
anywhere that's particularly good to be
here and I'm honored to be here with
general McChrystal who I admire
enormously I think all of you know he's
a soldier soldier and one of the best
Bob gates said one of the great warriors
of our time so I'm really happy to be
here with you and I we we cross paths in
Afghanistan and I may have crossed paths
with a couple of you here over the
course of time but this is a this
important conversation and and I'm
really pleased to take part in it with
all
because we're living in a very dangerous
world a world an enormous upheaval and
complexity some of the choices that we
face in terms of public policy are just
not as clear-cut as they were I think
often during the course of the Cold War
where it was pretty bipolar and we were
in a different kind of driver's seat
back then with options playing out
differently in many ways and the clarity
of the weaponry and the tools available
the various players were considerably
different with the Soviet Union with the
tamping down of much of the sectarianism
and religious components of life and you
know a person like Tito and Yugoslavia
to just quash it and they sat on it but
when the Berlin Wall came down a whole
bunch of forces that had been compressed
by virtue of totalitarianism and the
divisions of the world suddenly were
released and that's been an explosion
that we've had to deal with all of us in
public policy terms I happen to come to
this table with a very very deep belief
in special for a special ops capacity
it's no secret that I was one of the
strongest but yet unsuccessful advocates
for much greater Special Force
deployment during the course of early
days of Syria because I thought it would
have tipped the balance and I thought we
would have had a different outcome and I
also was extremely impatient with the
way in which we approach destruction of
Isis because I thought every day that
Isis was alive that narrative was
dangerous narrative and it underscored
the impotence and reluctance in the
Western world
to do what we have to do and what we've
ultimately done I had no doubts when we
put together the coalition which I put
together that we were going to succeed
never a doubt but there were awful lot
of lives lost an awful lot of
communities disrupted an awful lot of
narrative created by virtue of the delay
in using the force and capacity that we
have and I'm not talking about putting
special forces into harm's way in the
context you're in harm's way the minute
you're there
but I wasn't talking about clearing the
streets of Raqqa or doing any of that
I thought we would have organized the
YPG don't a lot more that we could have
done done it faster I think we could
have even perhaps even built a larger
Arab contingency on the ground to do
things for us and we should have done it
and and it's you know I ate for Syria
and what is there today as a consequence
of the reluctance to take action and as
you all know I stood up pretty clearly
and boldly on a Tuesday I think it was
and talked about what we're gonna do in
Syria and then we wound up by Friday not
you know making a different choice and
just on some degree David Cameron
screwed that up by going to Parliament
losing which we had no idea he was gonna
do I mean it just blindsided us and we
were on a phone call with about a
hundred members of Congress so on a
Friday in the morning many of whom were
saying well he gonna come to us you know
look at what Cameron did we're a
democracy we have to respect that
process and so forth notwithstanding
that you know I think we had different
set of options but let me come back to
the premise that I just put on the table
special ops
I learned a long time ago and I was not
a special I mean we were a kind of
special ops in what we were doing in
that Nam but we weren't trained as
special ops operator we were so
self-taught as we went along
a lot of improvisation as we were going
up and down the rivers of the Delta with
a lot of SEAL Teams and you know we had
Delta Force other people with US Army
Special Ops and so forth but we were
pretty much improvisational but I
learned you know it's just much better
to sneak up on people folks like hide
and seek and capture the flag you know
quick in quick out it's easier to be the
guerrilla it's easier to be the the
insurgent and I think we see the
difficulties of trying to fight back
against insurgencies law enforcement
military homeland security all these
folks you got to get it right 24/7 365
if you're a bad guy you only have to get
it right for an hour 10 minutes or at
chosen moments along the way there's a
hell of a lot harder to have a
prophylactic blanket of some kind that's
going to protect you all the time
we've done an amazing job I am in awe of
what we have been able to accomplish
across the board and breaking up things
and making things happen but I may be
wrong there's always room for error and
human judgment but I don't think we are
looking at a world in which in the near
term we're going to have World War 3 or
major conflict obviously have to be
prepared obviously you have to have a
deterrent capacity that is meaningful
and deterrence is real there's really
our definitions of where you get your
deterrence from but manat you know other
than Putin violating all international
norms by doing what he did in Crimea and
screwing around in the eastern part of
Donbass the reassurance program we put
in place for the frontline States has
worked and the four billion dollars we
put on the line and the additional
divisions we deployed and the tanks we
put on the ground that's worked and as
dangerous as the world is I don't think
Putin wark him John and are looking for
annihilation
so there was going to be these
calculated steps but extremists are
different terrorists are different they
don't think that way they're ready to
give up their lives they don't care
about dying dying is better for many of
them that's a different kind of enemy
and it's a different kind of concept
that you have to deal with and there
the battle is going to be and I think
it's there for the long-term
by the way Special Forces is going to be
the key to our ability to be safe and to
be able to do what we need to do to
protect ourselves and to help our allies
and to stand by people again and again
and again whether it's Boko Haram or
al-shabaab or al-qaeda or you know group
of crazy loony people have come together
in Libya now and they're spreading out
into Nigeria and Mali and so forth
that's a fight that's real and it is a
threat that is real and it's going to
remain a threat for the foreseeable
future
meanwhile incomprehensibly in my
judgment we have a group of people who
have allowed a a persistent ideological
group of folks to kind of hijack real
thinking about where the world is going
in terms of defense policy and threats
and the result of that is I was just at
the Munich Security Conference and we
had a night we had a national threat
initiative group of folks who were there
Sam Nunn you all know and Sam's very
thoughtful on this Ernie Moniz who as
the energy secretary had
responsibilities for our nuclear weapons
and so forth and a lot of veterans of HW
Bush and George W Bush and so forth
bipartisan group non-ideological all of
whom expressed deep concern which I
share for the direction of our national
security and and defense
posture that was articulated recently I
mean how can you have a posture on
defense that is actually respecting the
needs of our nation that doesn't even
mention climate change you can't but it
does doesn't mention it moreover it's
talking in terms of sort of unilateral
modernization of the nuclear arsenal but
believe me I know we need to modernize
some we were there things we have to do
in terms of warheads and capacity that
provide you with assurance that your
deterrent is strong and in a state where
it needs to be but we're on an automatic
pilot folks to a new arms race with the
potential loss of the INF treaty and the
potential loss of the START treaty which
Ronald Relic Reagan helped us put in
place when he said with Gorbachev
meeting in rec you Vic this is insane we
got 50,000 warheads pointed at each
other that's where we were we went in
the other direction folks we're down to
15 50 years of not vicinity and we could
go lower reasonably and ought to try to
because every step you take in a world
where you're trying to reduce the
capacity for a nuclear confrontation
actually makes the world safer because
it means you're reducing the capacity
for mistake of reducing the capacity for
stupidity you're reducing the your
you're reducing better better said you
are changing the way in which you
approach conflict resolution and your
hopefully resolving conflicts in better
and more effective ways so I I think
we're in a very tricky place right now
to be honest with you and as Bob Gates
used to remind everybody again and again
you know if you if you're not prepared
to invest in diplomacy if you're not
prepared to do what you need to do to
reduce threats in other ways you better
provide more bullets so to speak to the
Defense Department and we've grown
smarter about that I remember when I was
in Afghanistan I went up in
Kunar province inand man I tell you this
Navy captain I was commander was the
head of the operation up there and I was
as impressed as I have ever been by a
military briefing anywhere at any time
by this young guy who was philosopher
mayor psychologists development director
governor and soldier all at the same
time it was absolutely stunning he knew
every tribe he knew every tribal leader
he knew them by name he knew who was who
what the interrelationship was what'd he
have to do to work this it was as fine
as you get and better than any agency
briefer or State Department briefer in
Washington DC that's what we have
developed it that's what you all have
developed today you deserve enormous
credit for it but we're not putting it
to proper use and we're not supporting
the interrelationship between the
kinetic capacity that you need and the
prevention and development capacity and
the governance capacity I spent hours
with Karzai and hours with Abdullah
Abdullah and with Ghani to get them to
be a government I mean twice I had to
get Karzai first or we have to get a
Status of Forces Agreement and we have
to move forward on an election that he
wasn't accepting that was one round and
then we had another round when Ghani
came in and they were all down in the
election and we couldn't get a
government and I negotiated that and we
got a government so I'm pretty aware of
the challenges of governance in
Afghanistan but you know I'm a
Afghanistan I say this to people all the
time it is not Vietnam and we have to
stop thinking of everything
generationally and otherwise in terms of
it always it's not but it's moving in
the wrong direction if we don't do more
to deal with the corruption deal with
the governance challenge deal with the
capacity of the forces to actually
provide security and move out into the
communities reduce the heroin production
90
that three billion bucks a year to
insurgency and we're paying for part of
the insurgency part of the Taliban are
getting money from the money we're
putting in there because they got all
these deals and the Afghan government
turns our money over to the Taliban who
then agree not to attack them here or
there and you get these unholy
relationships and it's complicated
as you know their name buddy but given
what's happening with Iran and with
Russia and the proxy component of this
not to mention the fact that you know
when we started this operation in 2001
there were eight eight hundred thousand
people in school in Afghanistan and they
were almost all boys now you got eight
million-plus and 45 percent or so or
girls and they started when they were 10
years old and now they're 20-something I
mean that's change in the making and you
think of 10 years 15 was 17 years we've
been there now so for 16 or 15 of those
17 years you got a young generation
coming up who are going to be educated
who have a different attitude or one a
different future can't just walk away
from that
you can't just suddenly say to them you
know when disinvest in this plus the
reason we went there originally was to
prevent uncovering spaces from being
able to attack us again and given what's
happening in Pakistan with that Conny
network and the ISI and that unholy
relationship and a whole lot of other
difficulties we face it is pretty
critical for us to remain vigilant and
have a sufficient level of a platform
that you're able to perform and as I
know stem believes if you don't have
people on the ground folks you don't
have Intel you won't know what's going
on so you've got to have a sufficient
level to have enough Intel to know who
you're trying to target and who you're
trying to stop what you're trying to do
so there are a bunch of reasons why I am
I'll wrap this up why I'm a big believer
in in Special Ops I mean getting the
larger picture right in terms of where
we spend the money well we spend the
money what we're spending it on and what
we're doing with an understanding that
we're gonna have to be ready to help
people in certain parts of the world or
to go in and attacks
people and take them out on short notice
because they represent a clear and
present danger and a threat and that's
gonna go on for quite a while I'm afraid
because we got a lot of folks out there
for whom in this world of media social
media of knowing what everybody in the
world has and what they're doing and not
sharing in it 8 what is it we got two
billion people between the ages of 15
and 24 mischief age I call it we have
you know a billion eight people between
the age of 15 and zero
and about 400 million them are not going
to go to school I know a lot of
Americans don't think that's our problem
that I do I think that's part of the
security threat and I'll tell you an
apocryphal story about why I think that
I went to a country in northern Africa
or remain nameless in the early part of
my tourist Secretary and I sat down with
my counterpart the foreign minister who
was still playing a role in the
international scene and we went out to
dinner and I said to him you know about
40% 35 percent of a country is Muslim
and I said how are you managing your
minority population what do you what are
you doing to sort of shape the future
and he said you know John
we're terrifying we try to do we can
within the limits of our resources and
our capacity but he said but you know
the bad guys the extremists are
targeting 12 and 13 and 14 year old kids
and they take them away from the family
they pay them a stipend and they take
them into their school and and they
indoctrinate them they completely turn
their heads into becoming acolytes and
then they don't have to pay them anymore
he said they send them out back into the
community to become recruiters and these
are your future organizers your future
suicide vests and so forth and and he
said you know this is the sentence that
hit me that was so critical he said John
they have a thirty five-year plan and
they're patient as hell and disciplined
as hell and we don't even have a
five-year plan that's our problem and
that's where special operations are
going to be so critical to us and Intel
gathering is going to be so critical to
us in our ability we're gonna win I
believe that but it's like climate
change we're gonna get to a carbonless
better sustainable energy policy the
question is are we gonna get there fast
enough and that's the question with
respect to terrorism are we going to let
Nigeria fall apart are we going to let
the DRC you know shred and we can allow
these dictators to break their
constitutions and go for third terms and
destroy a rule of law or are we going to
be sufficiently investing in these
places not because it's you know
do-gooder Gugu tree-hugging whatever you
want to call it but because it's in our
interest that's how we're gonna build
our security that's how we're gonna
protect ourselves know what's happening
in the world know who is plotting know
who is buying weapons know who is
funding illicit activities and and be
able to join in partnership with
countries all around the world and
present a significant enough front that
the world is convinced that our
leadership is important that we mean to
lead and that we are prepared to stand
up and fight for our principles not
wince and not go south and not suddenly
turn to the world and say hey this is
too much for us where we're moving away
from a world order that brilliant people
put together in the aftermath of World
War two and a century that took tens of
millions of lives because we didn't do
the kinds of things we needed to build
structure and build rule of law and live
by some values and principles I think
special operations is to me really
anybody who was with me in the State
Department or knew what I said in the
Senate as chairman the Foreign Relations
Committee
I've always argued but that's the real
tip of the spear that's the place we got
to start that's the place where we could
accomplish enormous ly enormous ly
important goals and we've got to factor
it in more effectively to this macro
[Music]
shaping of a strategy to deal with the
world that we're living in today not the
world we wish we had not the world we
had before but the world we're actually
living in today so it's a longer
introduction that I meant to give you
but there it is I know my role up here
today it's to dumb down the conversation
so some of you can understand it well
fine only the uniform of the day with
surgeons guys it's a no it's an it's an
honor sir and and we don't have that
many people in the country thinking
these days about anything we got a lot
of people communicating but not many
people thinking and to be next to
someone who's been thinking a long time
and is able to articulate it's a real
honor there are a lot of people in the
room here today that I have a special
relationship some of you are in my class
so you have to cheer because you're not
your grades aren't final and then
they're a whole bunch of people here
that I served with either very directly
or indirectly and and I appreciate that
so I owe you something and so I'm gonna
start by just giving some advice I'm
gonna give some advice on retirement
because retirement is not bad first you
got to decide where you're gonna live
but it's pretty easy because your spouse
will decide that so you just go there
the second thing you got to get a
kegerator and that that's that enables
everything else you then have got to
start thinking about what you did and
I'll be honest with you here I've spent
now seven and a half years since I I
left the service thinking about what I
did at second guessing and not being
false humble here there are a lot more
things that I got wrong and we got wrong
then I ever realized
or wanted to admit there are a lot of
things they weren't sins of commission
they were things we didn't know we just
didn't understand and we we walked in
with a very limited view and therefore
we tried to interpret that well enough
to act and do some pretty big actions
that had big implications and we were
ignorant not evil but ignorant and there
was huge cost to that and then that the
other thing you do as you in retire you
watch the people that you served with
and you see what they do after you leave
and that's a source of huge project you
know when I see Mike Nagata and Scottie
Miller and and the others of you and I
see what you have done and what you
become it's it's pretty humbling but I
also see what you have in front of you
what you've already done for now almost
20 years and what you have in front of
you that is that's a huge challenge I
felt what I do is I there's no way I I
can add much to what secretary said
about the world in general so while I'll
bring it down and sort of just throw my
view on that Afghanistan part to it I
going in and I spent a lot of time with
President Karzai because that was my job
and so I'd go spend a lot of time and
you don't really make great progress
until you spend a lot of time with
someone because there's a certain
everybody's got their talking points and
then after that you're just talking and
then at some point you start telling the
truth and he used to repeatedly we'd be
sitting there after a while and you go
Stan why is America in Afghanistan and
I'd look at him because we've been
through this you know
I'd kind of rolled my eyes but the first
time I remember saying a and I'd go
through what we're trying to do and he
says now there is no way you are here to
make Afghanistan a more stable place
that doesn't make sense that's
nonsensical you have a greater strategic
goal to have a base in this part of the
world to do this this and so you can
stair-stepped other places and you know
I'd look at him and I'd say no I'd like
to tell you we do but if we do it has
not been shared with me
we actually are are thinking much more
narrowly and much more short-term than
that and that really gets at the heart
of I think how we think about
Afghanistan I would start by if you go
back to our relationship with
Afghanistan it's sort of been stopped
and started up until the 1970s they were
an interesting country that people would
go to and visit and that was no big
problem then in 73 it started to fall
into the perception that was in the
Soviet sphere and so that was worrisome
without taking over the government what
not then when the Soviets went in on at
Christmas 1979 remember that was only
six weeks after the American Embassy in
Tehran had been seized so against that
backdrop against that cold war backdrop
against a lot of other things happening
American America not having a good 1970s
suddenly it looked different and so we
went through the Afghan war and with the
Soviets and we provided money and and
weapons and at the end of that war there
was that famous fax CIA element did said
we won and we sort of beat our chests
and we said they had their Vietnam now
we won and then we sort of packed up and
came home went on to other things and
the Afghans not all of them but a lot of
them said no wait a minute
we just lost 1.2 million Afghans
fighting against your Cold War enemy who
you've never fought which is true point
we just lost 1.2 million and now you're
leaving said hey we helped you we
enabled it would give you money in arms
then they go really for 1.2 million
killed and so there was this sort of
disbelief that we would turn and of
course when we turn away they're their
first fear of course is Pakistan and
there's there's great reason for that so
you have an abandonment mentality and
then through the the 1990s is they tore
themselves apart with civil wars and it
was really hellish we paid no attention
to it but it was just really difficult
what happened
in much of Afghanistan during the 1990s
then the Taliban came in and that led to
another series of dramatic events so
that when 2001 happened and the towers
went down and we as a nation sort of
looked back again at that part of the
world we said al-qaeda came from there
we got to go there we got to get there
now we got a we got to take control of
that particular threat and so we we came
back in the Afghans I think took another
look and said ok we understand that we
overthrew the Taliban government and
then they stood and waited all right now
you're going to help now we're going to
sort this place out and there really
were pretty lofty expectations I was
there in the spring of 2002 and there
was great expectations and the level of
actual commitment was just extraordinary
really small I think 100 million dollars
was or 1 million dollars was put against
the army initially I was part of 18th
Airborne Corps and they said we're gonna
reorganize a whole new Afghan army and
I'm a chief of staff 18th Airborne Corps
and they said what are we gonna arm them
with they said well we'll pull stuff out
of the caves and of course this stuff
being pulled out of the caves was not
usable so we got 600 Romanian ak-47s
donated and we thought this is a big
deal but that's not how you build an
army you build an army with institutions
with training and whatnot so there was
this and then we were matched by the
Italians and Germans with the courts and
the police with an effort that was on
paper but in reality didn't didn't
accomplish or didn't amount to much so
in reality you had this gap between what
the Afghan people hoped and expected in
in the aftermath of the fall of the
Taliban and what they saw and many of
them their great fear was warlords would
come back into power because the reason
the Taliban had had some popularity as
they'd swept the Warlord's out then what
happened was of course the Warlord's in
many areas they came right in they
filled in some of them spoke English or
they were clever people and we
including many of us in this room we
failed to take the long view and we got
expedient we dealt with the person who
was most available and could do it and
so we we worked with a lot of people and
we empowered a lot of people that sort
of circle back around to be painful over
time so where are we now we're now you
know almost two decades past that
situation still difficult I agree with
secretary it's not Vietnam I also don't
buy into the grade your graveyard of
Empires thing if we fail in Afghanistan
we failed we can't go back and say now
now it's it's factors bigger than anyone
can do it's because we didn't do it
right and we've done sort of a stop and
start on things I'm a great believer
that we have got to take a long view of
these things the short-term view of
dropping a bomb or killing somebody is
necessary in the short term sometimes
but it never solves the problem people
say why can't we get back to World War
two when we didn't have to do messy
counterinsurgency and I'll tell you we
did do counterinsurgency in World War
two we just did it after the fact the
Marshall Plan was counterinsurgency it
was prevention of something that would
be horrific and we invested in it and we
actually it came out pretty well what
we've got to do in places like
Afghanistan in my view is it's pretty
basic and for people looking for the
clever plan I don't have one it's first
understand the place
remember when Scotty Miller came to my
office in 2000 late 2008 or early 2009
and he said we need to form Afghan hands
we need to get a bunch of American
military and diplomats you speak the
language go there repetitively know
people and have real relationships we've
tried to do that and unfortunately
there's been pretty tepid support from
the services to get in that right but we
should have done that years and years
ago and at the latest we should have
done it September 12 2001 so that was
sort of one thing the next thing is you
got to decide what your relationship
with the area is it would have been
better for me to be able to tell Hamid
Karzai
yet we do have a strategic view and a
strategic view is we do want to base
here whether we really want that or not
therefore we're invested in this so we
got to sort this government out because
we're gonna be on the ground here for
further foreseeable future decades if
the Afghan people when I got there in
2009 the thing I that really shocked me
is the greatest deficit there was
confidence they thought we were gonna
leave they thought the Afghan
government's gonna fall everybody was
hedging their bets because everybody
thought this was a Jenga tower and it
wasn't gonna hold up and as long as
people think that they don't invest they
don't make that commitments and whatnot
so our inability to convince people were
long-term strategic partners weakens us
dramatically and it in course embolden
is your foes now I know we don't want to
make long-term commitments around the
world cuz but you don't have to put that
much there remember the great statement
I think it was at the beginning of that
the First World War the British asks the
French how many troops they needed they
said just send us one guy and we'll make
sure he gets killed because then you'll
be invested as long as we can convince
people that were invested Karzai used to
say I remember when I were I was pushing
him to accept more troops so we could
get a level of security he says I want
more Americans I said good discussions
over he says no I want business people I
want you to invest here so that you are
invested and therefore you you care how
this place comes out and I don't think
we've been able to convince people of
that and and part of that is how we talk
about it how we deal with it so to get
to the sort of punchline of all this
special operating forces are going to
have to be really joined at the hip with
our diplomats and that includes
intelligence people and whatnot but I'm
our non-military solution and the
special operating forces are going to
have to be out there you're gonna have
to speak the language you're gonna have
to know people and that's gonna take a
lot of time and a lot of pain and we're
gonna have to spend time in places where
there's not a war but there could be at
some point and that's you know that's
sometimes jury and painful but the the
payoff on that is just extraordinary in
the long term
if we could do that I think we prevent a
lot and we'd make short work of some of
the things that have been really
difficult for us that's far could I ask
you a couple questions yes sir as we dig
into this conversation in 20 we went in
in 2001 2010 we went in and we gave the
Taliban a choice you're with us here
with them and so in 2001 we started to
do what we started to do to what degree
well first of all I'm going to repeat in
2010 there was a soldier I don't
remember the name who was asked about
the war there and he said well it's
actually you know we it's been 8 wars we
just did the same thing every year we do
have a new round of the same thing and
the question is whether given what you
know now and having been through what
you went through when we went in in 2001
I marry having this conversation with
general Keane I was I was outraged that
we had Osama bin Laden in the Tora Bora
mountains and I think our Special Ops
guys were at the base of the mountain
listening to him the New York Times
covering stories that we never sent them
up they never went in they were chomping
at the bit they thought I could get
Osama bin Laden right then and there and
I asked general Keane outside the Senate
one day we bumped into each other and I
said what the hell happened that what is
the story I said why didn't we do that
and he said risk aversion that was his
answer to me there I guess the president
was thinking in terms of having a war
like Clinton had with Bosnia Kosovo no
casualties and so we didn't go in and
the chase went on and our platform grew
could we have had a smaller platform
with a different strategy women went in
2001 we did we needed to do but we never
needed to buy the country we we went in
there to protect ourselves in a son
governed spaces the danger of the Osama
bin Laden's could so two questions
really could be taking them out there
earlier
had a different set of options if we had
not been so risk-averse number one and
number two could we have simply had a
different platform and said we're going
to be more limited we can protect
America this way but we don't have to
take over the country and try to defy
you know a country that's four hundred
years behind everybody else in the world
no that's it and those are two good
questions the first one is we went in in
the fall of 2001 primarily with CIA and
money and then some special forces a
little bit later and the Taliban fell so
much faster than everybody thought that
it was just sort of shocked and people
said ok this is the new way of war we
work through partners we enable partners
with air power and intelligence and
funding and they do the work and oK
we've figured this out this is not that
hard then you get to a problem like Tora
Bora where they don't have the capacity
there were special forces there with
Afghans but they didn't have the
capacity to root al-qaeda out of the
Tora Bora area you needed something more
and because of the geography of that
area sealing the border with Pakistan is
just probably impossible I think that
the Pakistanis estimated tens of
thousands of troops would be required
and then the request was made to put
American Rangers in and do that now that
might have worked but we were on this
decision that said no no this is my
perception of it no no we figured out
that we only work you know we work
through the local warlords and whatnot
and so it didn't work in in Tora Bora
everybody goes Wow ok then we were at
this position where you've got
Afghanistan you've toppled the Taliban
government the Afghan people are going
ok what now you just topple the
government and the Northern Alliance had
primary control but there were seven
competing groups and so it almost at
that point is a moral issue it gets to
what : Powell said you know you break it
you buy it and we're sort of there so I
think the decision there we could have
pulled out in the fall of 2001 but I
think it would have been pull out I mean
have a different platform not pull out
yeah but continue to protect the special
forces continue to obviously protect
ourselves against the resurgence but not
have this bigger footprint I think we
could have kept well first the footprint
was very small for the first few years
7500 people when I was a chief of staff
in the fall in the spring of 2002 were
allowed 7500 people in country and I
would have to fly people to car Sheik on
a bad for short periods to I could bring
other experts in to do it was stupid
because nobody was counting that the
people but and so we did this and so we
we had a tiny footprint and our problem
was we couldn't decide what it is we
were going to try to do and what we
really needed to do in my view then was
focus on the government of Afghanistan
focus on building their security and we
did that on the cheap as I described and
so we didn't make a serious effort to
build the Afghan military up would have
taken actually a bigger footprint than
we had in this first couple of years and
then by 2003 what had happened is we'd
fallen behind because the expectations
were still high and about 2003 the
Taliban who were shocked someone went
home to their wherever they lived in in
Afghanistan somewhat to Pakistan and
then about 2003 they see the Warlord's
have gone back in and they go back to
villages and they say well how's life
here and the villagers go up now it's
it's terrible because we got this
corrupt world so that's when they got
stand to what degree again I'm just and
I'm not this is not expressive I'm
trying to dig in and understand that but
to what degree did the rapid diversion
of energy in Washington from certain
quarters towards Iraq oh yeah and the
entire diversion of our effort into Iraq
detract from this war fighting war
planning for Afghanistan itself my sense
was back then we didn't have a strategy
we didn't know what we're gonna do we
didn't and we started going off to find
another war and all of the resources and
energy went off to the war we didn't
have to fight the fight of choice and we
left the one that we did have to fight
no that's exactly right it I would say
you asked how much and I'd say
completely
and although the forces that I was a
part of kept doing stuff there was never
enough of anything in Afghanistan in
those next few years and by 2006 that
war it heated up again and Afghanistan
had gotten pretty ugly and were fighting
some pretty short sword fights with not
much stuff then when I got there in 2009
I I left Iraq in 2008 went home for your
got back to Afghanistan 2009 what
shocked me and I'd been over there for
at least a month every year but but I
got the real wake-up call when your
charge is not only was the footprint in
Afghanistan small but it was the junior
varsity I'll be honest that the talent
in the military had gone to Iraq
powerful commanders had been over there
and they'd sucked the talent they had
good Intel Architecture good
communications architecture when I got
to Afghanistan in June of 2009 the intel
architecture was terrible the
communications were terrible you had
this really strange command and control
set up that we just kind of let go and
to be honest the staffs were manned by a
lot of individual augmentees and they
were good people but the bottom line is
and that's not the same as having people
and in Iraq by 2008 and 9 you had people
who'd been there three times people
really good at what they do and so was
it we had to start from in Afghanistan
again in 2009 from a very low bar but
now we built up a fair amount of callus
in the in the Afghan people in the press
and the American people there just
wasn't this excitement or confidence so
it and we're we face that same challenge
now and so when we were at max in
Afghanistan I mean we I remember there
was a point we had hundred thirty-four
thousand but didn't we have about 180 at
some point
no never 180 now but 130 for that I'm
confident I was gone before he got 134 I
asked for him but I wasn't there to wait
welcome them all okay
so the question is we now have 14,000
yeah differentially in terms of what you
would want to achieve we didn't seem to
get it done with 134 and now we're
working the 14 can we do what we have to
do yeah and that's a great question and
of course I asked myself this and you
guys did a better view than I do in 2009
we asked for all those troops not
because we wanted a big footprint
because the place was about to go down
the tubes and we needed to bridge time
to build the Afghan forces and I didn't
want to ask for any more forces in fact
I went over there thinking we weren't
gonna ask for any more forces we went
through this big analysis computer runs
all the smart guys on the staff and they
go we need 40,000 more troops I go you
[ __ ] me
I can't ask for 40,000 more troops they
said hey look and we went through a time
like general Rodriguez and I were
together we're just pounding on this
thing and then finally we go and you're
right so of course that was a then we
went met at the secret airfield with
secretary gates and the chairman and you
know dropped this one on their front
porch and I remember him going since he
goes you're kidding I said here's the
analysis let me take it we took it
through and he goes yeah I think you're
right but boy they're not gonna like
this in DC I said yeah
but I don't work in DC that's your
problem so the bottom line is we we sent
that group over to try to buy time so
that we could partner with the Afghan
forces to build up the challenge was
that when we put a deadline on it
everybody in their mind said okay that
deadline and everybody calculated it
differently there was some good some
people said great there's a deadline and
other people said now we can wait it out
and so there's a lot of debate about
that but the bottom line is I don't
think we made enough progress with the
Afghan forces to then be able to to
withdraw as fast as we did there was
progress made no doubt but but I don't
think we made enough now the question of
14,000 it's hard for me to judge one of
the things when people talk about 14,000
troops somewhere it's not 14,000
barrel-chested freedom fighters you know
out there bayonet and the enemy I mean
it takes a lot of people just to run the
airfield just to run the hospital just
to do all this kind of stuff
and so you can take 14,000 people before
you got one person who's actually out
doing anything and you say well that's
bad tooth the tail ratio okay I got it
do you want medevac do you want
communications do you need intelligence
tell me what you don't want and I'll cut
the number down and so therein lies you
know another part of the problem that's
why the numbers game is always a
challenge I think however that the
mission now ought to be twofold first
sort of be there meaning we are here if
the Taliban come close to taking it
you're gonna have to take us down too
and that's a problem for unit the second
would be build up Afghan capacity and
just stay with the Afghans and stay with
them through you know generations I
don't a problem that if it's not a huge
number of people what's wrong with
having people build them through
generations
I actually think being in that part of
the world to build that kind of
stability would be worth it
and it wouldn't be bad for America is it
worth 45 billion dollars a year well
yeah it's a lot of money I can't say I'm
really biased on Afghanistan so your
discount about half what I say because I
don't think we should discount any of it
because I think you know it's important
to figure out what the right mix is yeah
I and and the question is you also have
to define winning yeah what is winning
and what's the definition here are we
chasing the wrong definition of winning
is the definition of winning the long
term that you're talking about where you
have a platform that you know the
Taliban can't take over but you're not
pretending you're gonna have a
government that can deliver x y&z all
the time you got the problems but we're
we're meeting our needs which has to be
the driving force of this thing as a
rationale for why you're asking the
American people to pay 45 billion bucks
and what you're trying to get for it and
we're trying to get security we're
trying to get safety and ultimately I I
don't see the reason was there's we
can't say that we why are you in
Afghanistan because it's in our interest
there's nothing wrong with that and I
think then
being more stable as than original so
anything we do to help them and I think
today given the fact I mean one casualty
is too many we all know that but we are
not where we were and that makes a huge
difference to what the American people
are prepared to and appropriately can
stick with Specter how would you deal
with Pakistan now I never have figured
this out the tape on I it's very hard
for me to be fully descriptive with
seriously with the majiggy going there I
don't want to let me just say this that
I spent hours upon hours upon hours of
General Kayani I probably inhaled more a
secondary smoke it wasn't three cups of
tea it was about three thousand cups of
tea and I went up and down and back and
forth working on the ISI issue and the
Haqqani network and trying to figure out
how we were going to get accountability
there and I finally concluded that I
think Pakistan has such a profound
tension between it's very limited and
weak civilian government and the
military that it's really not a a fully
blossomed country in the way that we
think of it and it needs to be therefore
I think the ISI fundamentally calls its
own shots and certainly has very little
if any civilian control over it I'm not
even sure it has chief of staff of the
Army's control over it and that's a
problem it's a serious problem because
you've got the l82 India you have
potential explosion in the cold start
slash
you know ongoing very hot conflicts at a
sub level between the insurgents and
they you know their proxies I mean their
work in those guys and the Indians are
working people in Afghanistan as you
know so this is it's it's it's an
unbelievably duplicitous unbelievably
unmanageable and extraordinarily
disruptive to our goals I do not think
that the current administration's
decision just to sort of cut it off is
the way to work it it's not how it works
that's not psychology out there it's
completely contrary to it it will make
it harder to get these as it will make
it harder to get into it will make it
harder to you know you have to have a
certain sophistication as to how you
manage the relationship and it's going
to be less than joy every day you're not
gonna have you know it's not going to be
terrific but that's not the art is
compartmentalizing some of these things
and being able to get what you need to
the best of your ability and I think the
bombs going off in Kabul are a direct
reflection of the just hard-ass sort of
we've you know got to cut one point
whatever billion dollars off of you and
you guys you know that doesn't work and
you're seeing the did I hate the word
deep State but they're hard deep states
you're seeing that operation come back
to to hurt us right now and to hurt this
entire effort you got to be really smart
and careful about it so that's sort of
where it's we've got the expert of
experts on Pakistan and Mike Nagata
again thank you and did you did and
thank years ago general McChrystal sent
me for a one-year tour there in the w3
years gotta read the small print next
time country you're overflowing with
gratitude here it is I came to believe
in the almost almost exactly three years
I was there that the key that if you buy
the proposition that our principle
problem related to Pakistan as it
relates to Afghanistan easily the range
of Pakistani tolerance all the way to
active support of extremist elements if
you buy that proposition I which I did
and I still do then I think it it forces
you to realize that we are looking for
the solution to Pakistan on the wrong
order of their country what drives
Pakistani determination to maintain a
relationship with extremist elements is
about their poisonous relationship with
India yeah Americans I learned in three
years I was there that Americans find it
very hard to accept this proposition
because we think we're the most
fascinating people and what America is
trying to do in Afghanistan is the most
important thing that why don't the
Pakistanis get this the Pakistani do not
believe that Afghanistan or what America
is doing in Afghanistan is as
fascinating as we do that they they are
fascinated by it but they're far more
fascinated by their nuclear armed
confrontation and deeply emotional
mutual hatred between the Indian and
Pakistani populations fed by both
governments as you know and until there
is a way and I am not smart enough to
know how to
until we can find a way and it will take
more than just the United States it
would take an international community
effort to begin to untying the Gordian
knot between India will never relinquish
their relationship you're dead on it's a
it's a virtuous cycle and I saw it I
mean I saw it up close and personal with
the anger at the le t bombings and when
I'm back and forth and the tragedy of it
is folks that this is playing into the
larger nuclear challenge we face today I
mean everybody's got to really start to
focus the last thing we need is another
arms race and Pakistanis are part of
that because they are currently
modernizing a completely superior
nuclear capacity that's the irony here
the Pakistanis actually have a superior
nuclear capacity to the Indians but the
Indians have a far superior conventional
capacity which is what the PUC Stein's
fear so much is why they keep thinking
they have to grow their nuclear I mean
they're at a point now where they have
enough deterrence twice over it's
ridiculous but they're moving in that
direction and that is an agency which I
also think operates pretty independently
in there without the control directly of
the civilian government etc so it's very
dangerous and we all are gonna have to
try to find a way to get this subject
out there again when I came to the
Senate 1984 as elected we were all
debating the MX missile and you know
short-range in Europe and there are a
whole different debate but the people in
the Senate we had an arms control
observer group that had people like John
Warner and Ted Kennedy and Sam Nunn and
a whole bunch of really experience and
savvy senators and and all of us in the
Senate Al Gore myself we spent a lot of
time learning about nuclear policy and
deterrence and I was in I went
nuclear chemical biological warfare
school in the Navy so I've learned a
fair amount about it to begin with and
I've been intrigued by it but the truth
is that all but two advances in nuclear
capacity in the history of the
development of nuclear weapons starting
in 1945 when we blew up two bombs and
then the hydrogen bomb and then you go
the distance through silent submarines
long-range bombers Mervin all the pieces
of this every single one of them we were
first with the exception of two I forget
which two it was but there are about 20
stages of sort of this kind of
development plus so think about that we
were first and what drove us was always
the notion you're gonna outsmart or out
technology your opponent and that's
gonna protect you every single time our
opponent Soviet Union caught up with
bigger numbers of SS 18s or whatever it
is out there and we got caught in that
arms race because we were sitting there
not talking to each other for a long
time or totally suspicious and
untrusting which is appropriate we
shouldn't know I'm not ever talking
about trusting them but that's why
Reagan said you know trust but verify
you got to have a verification structure
so we finally got smart and started to
go in a different direction now we're
coming right back to this mistrust level
automaticity to taking a step to say oh
boy we can develop a satellite capacity
well they're gonna knock out our
satellites do we can develop or whatever
it just games it in a way that becomes
brutally expensive and leads you to the
capacity to have an accident or a
greater confrontation or spend money you
don't need to spend it's a case maybe
this is part of the problem with with
President Putin and Russia frankly is we
don't trust them we know what they're
doing to our democracy we know what they
did in in in Ukraine and Crimea and so
forth and it's wrong and it breaks law
and we'd were right to stand up to it
etc etc but Putin told George
bush to his face if you deploy ballistic
missile defense in Poland and then you
know Eastern Europe
you're gonna affect our sense of what
our threat is and you'll affect our
perception that we have deterrence
because you could knock down our
missiles before they even get out of
Europe whatever if that's where it was
and and and Bush said of you is so he
said Putin said to Bush if you do this
unilaterally he said by the way he also
said let's work on it together
let's jointly develop ballistic missile
bids the whole world could benefit from
it and we said no we're not gonna do
that we don't want to work with you blah
blah blah and it may have been right I
don't know but the bottom line was that
when he said the President Bush I'm
gonna have to respond if you do this
Bush said do what you have to do that
that's quote do what you have to do so
we now see the INF you know squeaky we
now see the START treaty which I work to
get passed in the Senate which takes us
down you know to the 15:50 being
questioned and and at risk and I don't
think any of you believe that given the
levels of our capacity today that it's
the moment for us to be unilaterally
talking about slick ins and and
submarine-launched ballistic missile and
other kinds of things maybe I'm wrong
but if we do that unilaterally folks
were in an arms race just be prepared
for it at a time where I know our
military desperately needs funds for a
lot of other things that we need to be
funding more effectively and efficiently
and in order to maintain our state of
readiness and given the budget situation
of our nation right now this is not
going to get easier it's going to get
harder so I just sound the alarm bell to
everybody that we really got to look at
this question of where we're going in
terms of nuclear when we have all these
other threats all the money we need for
Afghanistan and all the challenges of
development and other parts of the world
deployments through Africa Middle East
the potential of a war that we could get
dragged into between Saudi Arabia is
we're
I ran the challenge of Iran in Yemen and
Hezbollah that's a big big playing field
and to do things you don't have to do
because you're just kind of cruising off
in that direction I think is pretty
dangerous policy should we go to
questions will you run in the show Wow a
little scary admit
well it's a tricky one sure it is
look we I think we managed it as
effectively as you can we went up to the
line a few times in terms of our
training and work with YPG and
dependence on them to go after ISIL it
was the right strategy we want I mean we
did what we needed to do with them we
said we would move out of the
communities we moved into we didn't move
out very fast but we ultimately did and
I think we kept faith with it but this
is a this is that I mean it is viewed as
an existential problem by the Turks and
by our watch and I've never seen them
get as intense as they got on this
subject on any other subject there this
is really passionate with them and we've
got to be respectful of that they're a
sovereign nation they're a member of
NATO we have major interests in making
sure Turkey is not fully embraced in its
new relationship between Iran and Russia
and therefore I think we've got to be
really really careful and that doesn't
mean abandoning them at all it means
creating a sort of limited understanding
with respect to the distance we'll go to
the Turks have got to trust us on that
and frankly there are a few times where
we just went ahead and gambled that they
weren't going to be able to break and I
think they're pissed about that to be
honest with you
so I think we've got to do a little
fence mending and try to hold the thing
together the current thing is very very
dangerous in terms of its impact
potentially on Iraq and also on a
settlement in Syria now I think it's
important that we're on the ground I'm
glad we are I'm glad they know it I
don't think we should unilaterally
change that I think that's part of the
bargaining and the leverage for a
settlement and I happen to believe that
you know there's just a I mean haven't
been saying a lot publicly on this can I
ask you all to respect that but I don't
really believe that there is a deficit
with respect to
diplomacy in that entire region and and
you know Yemen we had a proposal on the
table which I left on the table when I
left
yeah which Hadi had signed on to they
had all signed on to it the Saudis
signed on to it I actually got the
hootie and Saleh to sign a piece of
paper to the effect that they were ready
to buy into that deal and go to Kuwait
and finish this nonsense and I called
the Saudis the night before I met with
them in order to get it and the Saudi
said you were on board we're 100% ready
to do this
I came to Saudi Arabia to Riyadh the
next day with the paper signed and
everything done and Hadi who was their
guest in the country who has no forces
at all for whom their entire his
existence in Saudi Arabia was allowed to
become the problem and the Saudi said
well howdee says he's can't do this now
he's not on board he won't you know and
frankly it was just a total walk away
and and and in order to allow the
continuation of what's happening in
Yemen where I think people some people
still believe in the potential of
military victory which is absolutely not
going to happen just not going to happen
people forget that you know Gamal Abdel
Nasser lost 45,000 Egyptians there in
the 50s or 60s and this is gonna go on
and on and on and and you all know the
difficulties we've had in terms of the
targeting and the efforts to manage it
and so forth so my feeling you know it's
just we got to be much more strategic
much more engaged much more involved in
leveraging the kind of behavior we just
we expect from some people and we're not
right now we've given a free license a
total green light and that is what is
potentially capable of running amok here
you know the Saudis are on a very
focused strategy with respect to cut our
and and Iran and if Bibi starts getting
even more focused on that depending on
what Iran chooses to do this is to me
far more explosive than a
the place right now in the world other
questions
everyone sir sue you started your
comments about being an advocate for the
soft platform and how you were
disappointed in the time it took to
essentially to prove it to go after ISIL
or Isis whatever is being called today
with regard to the overall picture of
how we approach foreign terrorist
organizations do you think our current
platform takes too long do you take
action against them or do you think
would be more effective option to
essentially defeat that organization at
the grassroots level so I'm just looking
at a better feeling more effective what
to start to try to defeat them at the
grassroots level so before they start
gaining influence
I absolutely believe it's more effective
to deal with them at a grassroots level
but that doesn't necessarily mean
kinetic to start with there are other
ways to to deal with them but yes we
absolutely ought to be engaged in that
way no question about it
and I have a feeling that if we are and
we do it right if we're if we're
thoughtful I mean if we really I think
general said this you know he didn't
understand certain things but none of us
did you know we didn't know what we
didn't know to some degree in the very
beginning of some of these things but
historically we've had a tendency not
always but we have a tendency as
Americans all of us to see other
countries and other conflicts through
our lens not through the lens of the
folks who live there and who you know
whose country it is and I think we're
getting better much much better and that
is what has developed over the last
years we're really getting more
sophisticated these kinds of conferences
and other things are helpful in getting
us to see where we had a blind spot or
where we didn't ask the right questions
or where we ignored something and now we
are much much better we're still not as
as thoughtful as we might be on some of
those things if we know the politics
better in a country for instance we know
what the history of the players are and
we
don't go in and play to the aspirations
of the wrong people who will use us or
who abuse us we have a much better
chance of perhaps nipping some of those
things in the bud before we have to get
kinetic oh I wouldn't hesitate
personally but we know they're really
bad people there we know they're
affiliated with I mean if it's Isis 3.0
who are now moving into the Philippines
who are moving into some Asian countries
who are in North Africa in places that's
dangerous and that's those are the folks
we got to be able to go after now and we
got to do it fast and and I think you
know I'm very supportive of some of the
deployments we have that are attempting
basically to do exactly that well we'll
have to tell you I mean when I was in
the Senate particularly in the last
couple of years I was on the super
committee and I was looking at trying to
get a macro deal on our budget that
would have dealt with entitlements and
tax code and everything which is really
part of the mix of where we have to find
the balance in our budget which is
grossly out of whack right now and even
dangerously more so in the last week I
mean folks I don't look on when I first
came to the United States Senate I voted
for the gramm-rudman-hollings deficit
reduction Act I mean I was an early hawk
on the deficit as a Democrat and I led a
fair number of people I think to that
watering hole that
period of time so I'm not you know
wild-ass spending here and there
wherever and we actually balanced the
budget in the 1990s people forget that
balanced the budget of the United States
and in the 1990s so we were very aware
gramm-rudman-hollings we were very
responsible about it we know how to do
it we could balance our budget again we
could get this thing in line and it
involves a balanced team where you're
you know specifically choosing to put
the money within the defense package and
the domestic package etc I'm now five
years away from that and I don't I'm not
current I want to give current but I'm
not current today in exactly what
choices have been made fully within the
fence part about that I know our
procurement system is a mess and all of
you know it we waste and everybody
people have tried to tackle we waste
unbelievable and that's money we
duplicate triplicate we overspend we
contract badly we just a whole bunch of
problems in in procurement and that's
the first place I'd start before I get
into a weapon system of one kind or
another but then I'd look very very
carefully at a lot of the systems were
using for are they synced into what
we've just talked about for an hour do
they do the kinds of things that are
going to give you the biggest deterrent
increase and the biggest safety margin
or are they want to do things that some
particular element of our defense
establishment has decided they really
want versus what they really need and I
think there are some weapons systems
given what I've described to you today I
don't think we're gonna I I just you
know I want to be prepared but I don't
think we're gonna see you know Warsaw
Pact invasion of your I don't think
we're gonna see a full-scale naval
warfare battle or something and I think
in today's world with the kind of
missiles that we have a lot of ships
aren't going to be floating for long if
we do I mean I think you just got to be
realistic about what happens if you're
really getting into the war gaming of
you all have done that and so if I and
you see how
quickly things go into a pretty
difficult place so I'd look at those
very carefully and begin to judge I want
people on the ground in places doing the
diplomacy doing the developing doing the
governance assistance and doing the
kinetic pieces we've talked about here
that take out bad guys when that's the
only thing you can do and that's the
best deterrent there is if people see
that the United States of America
together with Europe I think that's one
of the salutary things of what we've
done in Afghanistan
you remember coming to Brussels I think
how many people do we have we had 50
some nations around that table all of
them committed some not with you know
frontline forces on the ground but with
things we needed to make it all work
they were in the hospitals or they with
their training or they were doing a
policing or whatever it was but that's
the that's what we need and if people
see us determined to follow through and
get that done that has a very powerful
message in building the diplomatic beast
and development piece the other pieces
that make it work and I'm for putting
I'd be fighting hard to get more of the
resources there rather than into some of
these ten year away highly technological
unbelievably you know complicated and
expensive systems that might go out with
the first satellite that goes out or the
first cyber attack that takes place I
mean talk about a threat cyber cyber
cyber folks the whole whole system can
come down if somebody's assist to taz
some of these teams are on the ground
that are wreaking havoc nowadays so
cyber bothers me a lot more than some of
the other potential things and areas you
see written out and we got to factor
that in far more effectively I if we got
to save money in DoD I'd start by taking
active duty officers at grad school and
put them on half pay
seems small would make me feel good now
I completely agree the secretary and
that would hurt our beer budget it's a
but I agree with him but I would add
something as well a lot of what we used
in Iraq and Afghanistan wasn't developed
until we were in Iraq and Afghanistan
remember EM wraps and whatnot unmanned
aerial vehicles some other things and so
I really think we're at a time where
equipment is not going to be developed
the technology is not going to be
developed in the military over a long
time and then go to commercial uses it's
the opposite now it's it's commercial so
I I would invest on people because I
think you know what we've talked about
developing skills and familiarity and
then I would try to set up our
development process so we can sort of
wait and see what what's happening and
then start producing stuff there's some
risk in that but I actually think with
processes to build things now and
whatnot the risk would not be crazy I
mean you have to have certain things but
I but I would wait and see because I
think swarming UAVs railguns high-energy
labor are lasers a lot of what we have
is going to prove not useful but we
don't know which and even wargame it
doesn't tell you yet I think you're
going to kind of get in it and you go
out guess what we need more of this and
so we need to be set up to how do you
build more of that as quickly as you can
with the with the product improvements
and I don't think any other country
right now couldn't compete with us doing
that China will be able to but I think
that's the right approach sir gentlemen
thank you for your comments today my
name is Lieutenant Colonel Brian price
from the combating terrorism Center at
West Point
both of you had spent ridiculous amounts
of time with senior leaders from from
other countries and so when you talk
about some of the most important leaders
that the United States have may have
played a hand in putting in power I'm
talking about people like President
Karzai and and Prime Minister Nouri
al-maliki
only for us later to have a little maybe
a little bit of buyer's remorse in terms
of how they centralize power and and let
corrupt governments and so when I look
back at our own history and when we were
a nascent democracy I think there are
times when we may have been more lucky
than good because when we started out
our organizations our institutions were
similarly a mess
we had leaders like George Washington
that were able to take our country when
they when we had inflection points and
so given the backdrop that you know
moving forward there might be some more
cases where we might play a role in
putting leaders in two countries whether
you take Syria or potentially North
Korea and others have we picked the
wrong horses in these countries for
these leaders I don't want to say picked
back supported at least initially or do
you think that those two individuals
were put into situations where the the
environment itself made it impossible
for any leader to to lead their
countries the way we would like them to
well
Marv's remorse is not reserved to other
countries I knew that was coming we
don't do it perfectly either and I'm not
just referring I mean through history
Winston Churchill has said that
democracy is the worst form of
government in the world except for
everything else and I think that's true
I I love democracy and I would always
fight for it died for it but it ain't
working very well right now here it's
broken
and it's broken because we have a
fundamentally financially financing
system that is that's corrupt I don't
know how to call it otherwise it
imprisons the agenda of our nation folks
it's not that the money ORS gets what it
wants it doesn't I'm not suggesting that
and I'm not suggesting there's a trade
and a buy and I said it's when I say
corrupted it's in a writ large sense
that I'm talking about it it sets the
agenda the average American their voice
does not have the same ability to get to
the halls of power and and get a bill on
the floor or get a special page in the
tax code I often went out to my
constituents in Massachusetts and I
asked what I say how many of you have
your own page and in the tax code and of
course not a hand would go up but I've
got news for you there are plenty of
entities that have their own pages in
thousands tens of thousands of pages of
tax code where they have a carve-out
that means they don't pay or whatever
Americans know this I mean Americans
this is why we have this growing sort of
populist nativist reaction in the
country because they don't see that the
Washington developed the delivering and
in fact what you had in the last
campaign was effectively a hostile
takeover of the Republican Party and it
came about because first you had the
Gingrich revolution which I remember
very well in the 90s and and it didn't
deliver
remember Rho V Wade was going to go away
tax reform was going to happen a smaller
government was going to be delivered
none of those things happen but then it
didn't happen with the next round which
was the Tea Party and then it didn't
happen with the next round which was the
freedom caucus and that's why we are
where we are
people are rightfully angry because we
ain't delivery so we have a problem here
in our own country we have a
gerrymandered Congress you cannot have a
legitimate general election in America
in which the average person could go out
and challenge a member of Congress you
have a fair race we have a carve-out for
my parties and that's the Supreme Court
just decided one case in favor of
changing it fixing it and there's
another case coming I think from
Wisconsin or somewhere and who knows
where they come down but that would do
more to resuscitate democracy in our
country that a lot of other things I can
think about now I could go on but I'm
just under saying to you that it was
really hard as Secretary of State I'd
walk into a meeting with somebody and my
talking points you know a mr. Prime
Minister you've really got to get your
budget together and I could just see it
go you know so look at me like where are
you coming from you know you got to have
clean hands and credibility to deliver
some of these messages so we're we're
handicapping ourselves a little bit in
that regard now that said it's not a
good idea to be picking people in any
country we should get that out of our
heads doesn't work it's gone back and
you go back in history of the last
century folks in Latin America and
you're in Asia gem and Vietnam I mean we
we shouldn't be picking people first of
all it's against our value system to be
doing that that way especially some of
the ways we've chosen to do it look what
we did in Iran 1953 Kermit Roosevelt we
took a you know at the CIA he was a head
of the CIA and we got rid of most attack
it was the you know democratic prime
minister of a country replaced him with
the Shah and then we got the revolution
in 79 and we're still living with the
implications of all of that and the
intensity of that so I am NOT for us
trying to pick a leader in a country and
to some degree frankly I mean again I'm
not excusing anything I mean Putin's
invasion of our democracy is is an act
of war it's completely unacceptable
and he ought to pay a huge price for it
and and and so forth but Putin I know
this believes that Hillary Clinton in
America tried to interfere in his
election and our ambassador was
regularly meeting as we do with the
Opposition in the embassy in Moscow and
they interpreted that as America giving
guidance to the opposition as to how to
beat him and you know they listened to
it whatever the conversation was so I
we've got to be really careful that's
all I'm suggesting is that and by the
way if any kind of regime change took
place in the in North Korea I assure you
it ain't gonna be us making a choice
it's going to be China so let's not
delude ourselves about the facility with
which that might or might not take place
or whether it's going to happen I don't
see that as and by the way the more
chatter there is about that the harder
it's going to be to get a solution to
the crisis and the peninsula because
that's part of what he fears he thinks
we are out for she in change and he
needs a nuclear deterrent in order to
prevent it from happening if you look at
Qadhafi you've probably asked the same
question of yourself so I hope our
policies will encourage democracy
encourage our values human rights stand
up as we must and should for for what
defines America and our influence in the
world and which has made a difference to
the luck we lenses and the baklava bows
and the people historically through
Voice of America etc all fair game we
should be doing that but the people are
going to decide in that country who
they're Democrats going to be and that's
the way it's going to be the strongest
and most successful for us I think yeah
you taint a leader if there's a sense
that we caused them to be in there
they're much better for us if everybody
thinks they didn't you know they did it
themselves but it just comes out alone
turn better I think we're at a time
we got one time one more all right
better be great do my best sir
Jalen thank you for your time Kevin Pat
Romero from 10th Special Forces my
question kind of a first would a
secretary care was just speaking to many
of us have in watching Russia and I
asked the last couple years come to
understand the true power of covert
influence campaigns
my question is Canon should the u.s.
engage in covert influence on a large
scale can we prevail over the narratives
of violent extremism and autocracy
without doing so and if so how well I
support covert activity I believe that
some things you have to do through
covert operations and the best thing you
do is keep them covert yeah let me add
on that covert however is seductive
opportunity you know particularly a new
administration comes in and and the the
new president says how do I solve this
problem and it gets a hundred thousand
men from the military and fifty billion
dollars and then he gets this very small
sexy thing we're just going to do this
and it's going to cause it and it'll
always be secret one it usually doesn't
work and it's never secret in the long
term and so I overt action strongly but
you got to be very mature about it if
you think it's the easy button it's
usually not and then particularly the
important about covert influence that's
another case where I do think we should
use it but we should use it with caution
because again it will likely not stay
truly covert forever and so if we are
start to be perceived as people who are
not purveyors of the truth and we are
doing this stuff then everything we do
will be discounted so the idea of Radio
Free Europe and things like that was
powerful the BBC during World War two if
people
thought that that was actually accurate
and so I think that we need to think
that way I'm not saying there aren't
instances where you wouldn't you know
put something that would be a clever
trickle on somebody but you got to
really think that through could i
underscore that with one comment to
everybody here whoever is in a position
of making a decision in the policy
whether its domestic foreign military or
not there was a phrase that i now always
ask myself no matter what the decision
is and it's just three words and then
what ask yourself and then what if you
can't answer that problem and too often
it's like afghanistan then what you got
to ask the question in them what and if
the and then what works out and you're
you're prepared to take whatever that
consequences but you got to know what
it's going to be perfect
[Applause]